hi I'm Paul fine from reason TV we're at
reasons la-based Studios here as some of
you may have heard the voters in
Colorado and Washington legalized
marijuana this past November but that's
not the end of the story a lot of hard
work is yet to be done and we're going
to talk about some of the implementation
challenges for the folks in colorado and
washington i'm joined today by David
Beaton stock he's the editor West Coast
editor of High Times Magazine and he's
also the the author of a new book called
legalized it we're also joined by Harris
Kenny he's a breezin poly policy analyst
and Harris is on the task force in
Colorado to give recommendations about
how to move forward with implementation
welcome guys thanks for being with us
and welcome to our studio audience today
as well the first question I have and
I'm going to direct this to you Harris
what why did the efforts in Colorado and
Washington work what were the strategies
that were used and what can what can you
all learn from the campaign successes
that can inform the implementation
efforts well I think the first thing to
recognize that there were years of
marijuana reform F election efforts
initiatives of the state and local level
that laid the groundwork and the biggest
thing that was pointed to after this
election in 2012 was the fact that the
campaign really invested a lot of money
in appealing to sort of the median voter
the campaign was tax and regulate
marijuana they focused a lot about
controlling the black market and they
focused on arguments that were that
convinced fifty five percent of the
voters a majority the voters that this
was a prudent direction to take it and
it wasn't a radical campaign John ingeld
for the Denver Post explained how
they've put on suits and ties and made
it ran a traditional campaign to
convince people and and I think that
that's pretty widely accepted as a
number of the reasons why they were
successful and David I'll ask you you're
in town what brings you to LA right now
we're having an event in Los Angeles
called the medical cannabis cup and
here in advance to that and also of
course to speak with reason and great
and they're going to be a lot of guys in
suits and ties at the Cannabis Cup um
there will be a few no doubt they might
be from the boe but what do you think
about that dressing up in suits and ties
and going out there to create change is
that created contrast or tension with
the the other parts of the movement I
mean I think we first of all lots of
people who wear suits and ties everyday
smoke marijuana whether they want to
work to legalize it or not so you know
we are representing who we are we're a
broad range of people I think that what
in addition to what you said what I
think worked in Colorado and Washington
is that familiarity with marijuana does
not breed contempt and that's whether
you become a user of it or you just know
that your neighbor is using it and we've
seen in Colorado and Washington through
medical marijuana and through these long
running campaigns the more people become
familiar with marijuana and marijuana
users the more comfortable they become
and to ask voters in a state like
Colorado that has state regulated
medical marijuana retail outlets to
envision a world where now any adult can
go into that same retail environment
it's just not such a leap and I think
you know one of the best arguments going
forward is the people who are most
familiar with marijuana and especially
retail sales of marijuana are the ones
who legalized first absolutely um next
question I have is you know our colorado
and washington state going to turn into
the next amsterdam's are there going to
be coffee shops there is there going to
be pot tourism what do you guys make of
old point this to David um it's no
surprise that I hope so I you know
Amsterdam is a wonderful city so there's
certainly nothing wrong with emulating
them I I think that if you're going to
say something is legal and that's what
the voters said in overwhelming numbers
then you have to treat it like something
that's legal you have to treat marijuana
like alcohol and not like plutonium and
you know what
in Colorado the messaging was let's
treat marijuana like alcohol well I can
go into a bar I can go into a liquor
store I can have people over in my home
and we can have the Great American Beer
Festival in Denver where thousands of
people gather to responsibly enjoy
alcohol and I personally don't see
anything that says marijuana should be
different great what do you think about
that Harris well the question
unfortunately even though it seems like
the intention of voters was clear the
intention of the elected officials
regulators and other people involved in
implementing don't necessarily share
that vision right away and so a couple
big questions need to be asked the want
the first one is can someone that's not
from Colorado or Washington from another
state or country purchase marijuana and
it appears that in both states that's
going to be the case which is a big step
another important question is how are
they going to handle a diversion so what
sort of regulatory regime and
enforcement is going to be put in place
to prevent marijuana that's legally
purchased from going out of state in
particular and so those regulatory
questions and questions about cafes and
things like that the answers are not
immediately clear in Colorado there's a
Clean Indoor Air Act which prevents
smoking indoors that was amended for
medical marijuana and will probably be
amended for marijuana as well but that
doesn't mean that other ways to consume
cannabis won't be allowed on site on
business sites and there's a lot of been
discussion about private clubs in
private residences and things like that
and so unfortunately we don't know yet
but I think the intention is to regulate
like alcohol and I think the intention
is going to be to try to get as close as
we can to that with the exception of the
fact that Colorado actually has a really
bad regulatory system for alcohol so we
don't want to copy it exactly verbatim
we want to hopefully learn from some of
the mistakes there and then one day we
will run a campaign to regulate alcohol
like marijuana and we will reform the
alcohol prohibition our regulations or
it might turn out to be something like
what's happening in Amsterdam now where
you can smoke your marijuana in the
coffee shops and spliff some pot and
marijuana mixed but you can't smoke
cigarettes inside you have to go outside
to smoke e-cigarettes that's a
reasonable model that
we can aspire to I think what about some
of the other legal ramifications you're
not going to be busted for smoking pot
or selling pot in these two states David
but what about other other other legal
ramifications if people are you know
smoking pot there certainly are and and
we really have to be careful that we
don't create second-class citizens when
we legalize and that's anything from can
you be fired from your job for using
legal marijuana can Child Protective
Services come into your family life and
make irrevocable decisions based on
benign marijuana use can you be denied a
student loan to go to college and that's
of course if you're 21 or older even can
you get a loan for your business if it's
a marijuana related business to me legal
means I can do something and there's not
irrevocable ramifications to it you know
if you can't drive a car if you can't
work your job if you can't bank if you
can't raise your kids in a responsible
way it's not legal and what people said
is we want this to be legal and so I'm
hopeful that that this kind of thinking
is is is recognized in the
implementation process yeah what are you
guys talking about in Colorado with
respect to these kinds of legal
ramifications well there's a lot of
change that needs to be happening and
unfortunately you know one thing that
activists and people that support
marijuana reform upset about is that
employers do have a right to terminate
at this point and likely will someone
for consuming marijuana if that's
against their employment rules or labor
rules and in the campaign in amendment
64 and amendment 64 was fairly
comprehensive it was a lot more it
opened up the doors to a lot more things
than Washington State did they did
preserve that right and they separate
medical and recreational I think the big
takeaway first is that the civil liberty
protections to possess marijuana and
consumer want in your home and for
adults 21 and over and the the civil
liberty protections they're going to
reduce prison populations and get rid of
the major costs are in place and
some of these others still serious costs
are going to take time there's going to
be cultural change employers are going
to change their hiring practices
communities are going to become more
sensitive but I think the big issues
have been taken off the table which is
incarceration and things like that and
it's going to take some time for these
other still important issues to get
hammered out it's going to take I think
a number of years one of the other big
questions people in Washington State are
looking at is how do you deal with DUI
related to marijuana because that's
what's built in to their ballot
initiative a ballot measure what do you
guys think about that what kinds of
conversations have you had with people
in Washington is that something that's
going to be a viable way to keep you
know people who are too high off the
roads or what do you think about that I
mean first of all I think that's not
only a valid concern the most valid
concern moving forward you know just as
I feel I have a right to use marijuana
responsibly I recognize that everyone
has a right to be on the roads safely if
you're impaired on any substance you
should not be behind the wheel what's
somewhat difficult with marijuana is
determining what impairment means it can
be difficult and it's tempting to say
well let's just draw this hard line but
if you're putting people in a situation
where they smoked a joint legally three
weeks ago but they're subject to a DUI
every time they get behind the car
during those three weeks that's not fair
that's not legal and and my big concern
as I said familiarity with marijuana is
what's moving this forward it makes it
hard for that level of society that
people really spec respect to admit that
they use marijuana because there's all
these negative consequences waiting for
you that might not be the criminal
justice system well in a DUI it is but
so you know there's ways to look at
active amounts of THC in the bloodstream
as opposed to just the presence of THC I
know there's a lot of efforts to work
that out I'm sure how it's coming
together you can you can talk more about
that yeah what's happening Colorado with
it sure so in Washington's initiative
first it was in the initiative and so it
said there's a 5 nanograms
of THC per milliliter of blood
immediately in there in amendment 64 in
Colorado that was not included but it
did state clearly that you're not
allowed to drive under the influence
which is already illegal it's still
illegal that said over the last three
years legislature has tried to pass a
DUI d driving to the influence of drugs
bill and it has failed because of the
fact that it would be through a blood
test and there's a again civil liberty
concerns there and law enforcement has
concerns about their liability and
whether or not they can be taking
roadside blood tests what they need to
take people into the sheriff's office or
police department to do the tests and
things like that I think the answer the
long-term answer for this is going to be
entrepreneurship I think it's going to
be somebody invents a non-invasive
saliva test something that works and I
hope they make a lot of money and
entrepreneurs if you're watching this
start entrepreneur get inventing talk to
engineers I think that's going to be the
long-term solution and I think anything
in the in the short term is going to be
an attempt we'll see you know I think
the biggest thing with these with these
duid bills is the ability to challenge
in court so it shouldn't be assumed
automatically if you have a certain
level of THC in your system that you're
impaired and I think that's the workable
compromise that everybody can agree on
moving forward and so hopefully that'll
be a feature in all of these duid
legislation or regulation rules things
like that great now as that's the sort
of political battle moves forward what's
your sense right now of who the friends
of the movement are and who the fuzz are
David I mean I think that both campaigns
did an excellent job of bringing a
really broad coalition you know in
Washington State you had a former US
Attorney you had the mayor of Seattle
City Attorney of Seattle and then you
know as far as from the High Times end
of things we the people who enjoy
marijuana have been pushing this issue
in a very grassroots way for 30 years
and for someone who's been at this for
ten years to see the corporate media
I'll use the term starting to at least
get this and reported in a responsible
way
has been great and has been a big part
of moving this forward I think that
every time somebody's aunt smokes a
joint and their chemo therapy side
effects go away we gained five allies
because it's not just that person it's
everyone in their family that's touched
by that and no one ever goes back I've
never heard somebody say well you know
this really helps grandpa in his last
years of life but [ __ ] everybody else
you know it should still be illegal but
wow what a miraculous plant but [ __ ]
I've never heard that so from friends we
are gaining every day proposed it's
still the same people people who make
money off of incarcerated marijuana
smokers in a variety of ways we talked
about entrepreneurs in the drug test
industry but obviously they're you know
prison guards all the IFS follow the
money if you make money off of
incarcerated people for marijuana you
are in favor of the status quo and I
don't see too many people outside of
that who still are well I should ask you
as well I mean back in 2010 when
Californians were excited about a failed
a ballot measure well we were we were
excited about it when we thought it was
gonna pass well yeah that's right right
and we're less excited about it now and
then people in Colorado have pastéis but
you know one of the things that happened
were a bunch of growers that had sort of
locked in they had market share they
came down to Oakland or walking around
with no on prop 19 what did did you meet
those folks did you talk to him and when
what was your take from are they rent
seeking bastards or how do you think
about I think it's a complicated issue
one thing I want to stress the people in
future initiatives is it's one person
one vote not one plant one vote so just
because somebody grows you know two
hundred thousand plants they still only
get to vote once and the population of
humble and trinity county and mendocino
county is not large enough that's the
Emerald triangle that's where the large
outdoor grows are I'm not giving a big
secret away I think you have two things
you have people who have been living an
outlaw lifestyle for generations
providing a plant to people that they
really want supporting the
families supporting their communities
the largest economic activity up there
is marijuana production and that's
whether you own the hardware store the
pizzeria the the boutique are whether
you want to go to a school up there that
has a good tax base for running programs
so to say now hey thanks for growing our
marijuana for three generations while
helicopters flew over your house but now
we're going to legalize it so we have no
you know fu I'm not with that but also
people have to recognize what keeps the
prices up and that's what they're
worried about is people getting busted
that's the prohibition tax and so in one
way you have a small group of people who
were very vocal and had a news story
that pot heads against legalization
that's a story even if it's ten people
with no support out ranting in the
streets you know so I think it got
overblown in a lot of ways I think well
I in my position for the last 10 years
I've dealt with nothing but people who
grow marijuana or are very tied into
this culture and the people i have met
who are not a hundred percent supportive
of marijuana legalization is a very very
small number and it was
disproportionately covered in the media
great well that's good to hear in lots
of ways and harris what do you think of
friends and foes in colorado well one of
the most interesting aspects of the
implementation in colorado is and this
may offend libertarian sentiments but
the regulators and bureaucrats have been
some of the best advocates for a
functional competitive system and that's
the folks of the Department of Revenue
and they're doing a great job in the
public hearing process throughout the
task force meetings basically laying out
what they think is important and why
they think a functional industry is the
best for them and I think it's it's good
basically their incentives align with a
productive industry that generates a lot
of money that pays them application fees
and pays tax revenue to them to you know
promote and allow them to continue to do
their activity they don't want a
fledgling tiny
grey market pseudo a legal business that
they can't make any revenue off of and
so because of that they've been really
pushing back on some of the bad ideas
that would limit the ability of
businesses to operate and grow and then
they've been supporting some of the good
ones and so that I think as one of the
most interesting stories and to their
credit the medical marijuana Enforcement
Division I don't dish out praise a lot
for public agencies so I really want to
be on the record I think they're doing a
great job and so that's one of the big
ones I think another friend to think
about is going to be the press corps the
Denver press corps folks with The
Associated Press the Denver Post
westward which is an alternative you
know locally circulated paper they're
doing a pretty good job I think handling
it responsibility in treating this like
a policy issue which is what it is and I
think that combination of things is
allowing Colorado to move forward and
I'm very optimistic things are going
well as far as treating this like a
serious issue which it is and what about
the existing medical marijuana
dispensary owners in Colorado are they
getting behind it or what what's their
role going forward and do you should
talk a little bit maybe get some
background about who gets to who gets
the priority when they get when it goes
retailer eventually sure so that's
definitely a huge aspect of it so in
amendment 64 it's really clear that the
medical and recreational industries are
separate but it's unavoidable that the
existing medical industry growers
retailers MIPP so the ingestible product
companies and testing companies and
things like that have a seat at the
table they're the ones that deal with
the Department of Revenue right now and
they've like they was saying they've
risked a lot to operate under violation
of federal law and so they deserve
credit for that and the amendment 64 the
language does say that they get a
priority or preference when applying for
recreational licenses as well and so
there's a few structural things where
they deserve you know it's important to
see where they're special or with it how
their unique but there are aspects of
the system today that they would benefit
from or that many of these businesses
would benefit from if it were to
continue and one of these is vertical
integration and so the idea is seventy
percent of the plants that are sold in a
retail location have to be grown by that
same business owner this is
operator and then thirty percent can be
wholesaled in the wholesale market and
there are some strong advocates in the
industry arguing to retain vertical
integration arguing against allowing
out-of-state investors to be owner's
equity holders in marijuana businesses
and these are the sort of protectionist
policies that would allow existing
businesses to stay in place and if these
policies aren't allowed indefinitely
they may be allowed in a sunset format
to allow a transition and so that that's
definitely a big challenge I you know
it's medical industry doesn't
necessarily have the same goals as a
drug policy reform er as a an activist
as an attorney that works in the
industry there's sort of a shared end
state but some of the in-between steps
are definitely gonna be different and so
it's not a single monolithic movement of
drug drug policy reformers great and
then the last question I have and this
is a question I think looms over all
discussions about legalization and
that's the feds you know over time are
the feds going to be a friend or foe to
the implementation process what do you
what's your best guess friend now I I
personally have been pretty encouraged
by what I've seen since the election and
I think the most encouraging part is I
think that they're finally afraid of us
and by they i mean the federal
government and US I mean the broad base
of support for marijuana legalization we
had a source within the administration
pretty much admit well the reason we
didn't get involved in trying to stop
this law in Colorado is we thought it
would hurt our reelection chances if you
look at the votes cast total in Colorado
and Washington marijuana legalization
outperformed the president so you know
on what basis are you going to come in
and do these things and and try you know
I think that the federal government I
you know I will say I'm pro-cannabis I
understand also some people say well
let's limit the harms of the these laws
and they're my allies but I I think it's
a good thing not for every person and
not all the time but I think society
will be
better place but I recognize the federal
government has a responsibility to stop
interstate traffic at this point no one
in Oklahoma said we want to legalize
marijuana yet and well some people did
but not enough that's reasonable but to
come into a state or to say I cannot go
into Colorado and have the same rights
as a Colorado right yeah that to me is
ridiculous and and then encouraged by
the non-response of the federal
government at this point great are you
equally optimistic Harris I am I will
say maybe the federal government to be a
frenemy right so they're friendly but
maybe also enemies I'll say one quick
thing the only clear thing that I've
heard that would say that would
definitely cause the federal government
to get involved would be if either
Colorado or Washington were to set up
state-run marijuana stores like you have
in a lot of states where you have
state-run liquor or alcohol retail
stores or wholesaling and dr. Sam Kamin
who's a law professor at the University
of Denver was also on the larger task
force he's basically said that's the
only thing that he can think of from a
legal perspective that would guarantee
the federal government would come in
because states would mean it would be
like if states were gun trafficking or I
mean it's almost impossible some people
have made the argument that they should
do that and I'm skeptical of the
motivations for that argument it seems
like that would be trying to set these
legalizing states up to fail and it
would be almost necessitating the
federal government to shut it down so
that's the only scenario i can think of
where there's definitely to be a problem
other than that it's wait and see so i
hope you're listening feds thanks
everybody thanks to david thanks to
harris and thanks for the audience so
it's great to have you here
special